à quelques heures du coup d'envoi de la
campagne hivernale les bénévoles et
salariés des restos du coeur n'ont guère
le temps de souffler l'association
distribue maintenant des repas toute
l'année certes mais dans les faits
l'hiver reste la période de très forte
activité avec chaque année le même
constat désespérant
le nombre de bénéficiaires va encore
être revues à la hausse
aujourd'hui je suis un petit peu inquiet
j'ai pas de chiffres encore mais la
tendance que qui me remonte de nos
différences entre ces une progression
des inscriptions pour la campagne
d'hiver qui est de l'art de 15%
c'est à dire qu'on a progressé elle
était déjà 15% par rapport à l'année
dernière
si cette année on progresse encore de
15% par rapport à l'hiver dernier on
risque de se retrouver sur l'indre et
loire entre 7000 et 7500 bénéficiaires
ça veut dire qu'à rentrer entre 40 et 45
mille repas distribués chaque semaine
mais pour y faire face les restos ont
évidemment besoin de bénévoles
ils sont presque 600 aujourd'hui en
touraine mais les bonnes volontés sont
encore les bienvenus des chauffeurs de
poids lourds par exemple le manque à
l'appel
je suis simplement chauffeur-livreur se
faire en amont du dépôt dans les centres
et on dispatche la nourriture qui est
préparé par des salariés au niveau du
dépôt mais je sais que pour la campagne
via depuis plus de livraison à faire
[Musique]
au cours de cette nouvelle campagne
hivernale les restos du coeur vont
passer de 19 à 21 centres de
distribution puisque deux ouvertures
sont programmées en janvier l'une à
château-renault l'autre à tour dans le
quartier des fontaines